La volta al món a peu, dia 307.
Sempre que em poso el barret després de tenir-lo doblegat pel matí,
em queda així raro.
Vaig dir quan me'l vaig comprar que no m'acabava de convèncer,
però era el que hi havia a Duxambe,
però ara m'està agradant molt, eh?
Crec que me'l quedaré indefinidament.
Era l'estètica que no m'acabava de convèncer,
però és que és molt ample i cobreix molt.
M'agrada, m'agrada.
Bueno, surto del poble aquest de...
de Híber, o Kíber,
on les bosses de plàstic estan prohibides,
segons aquest lletrero.
Torna a ser tard, molt tard,
començo a caminar a les 10 i pico.
Bueno, estic començant a arrencar després de la parada, eh?
Però això no hauria de ser normal,
perquè el sol surt a les 5 i pico.
Bueno, tot és igual.
Dia que ha començat una mica rúfol,
però ara bastant blau.
A veure què ens depara avui la carretera del Caracorum.
Estàtua, homenatge...
Estàtua molt ben feta, diria jo.
D'homenatge a...
Shah Doulat,
un alpinista paquistanès
que el 2022, fa 4 anys,
va coronar el K2.
Un any després va coronar
el Nanga Parbat Sense Oxigen,
el Gash...
Gasharbrum II,
Gasharbrum I,
i el Laila Peak.
Les 4 primeres són muntanyes de 8.000.
La cinquena no ho sé.
Bueno, aquest senyor va morir aquest any,
per tant aquesta estatua l'hem fet ara
i es nota que és nova.
Molt bé, tu.
Alpinisme paquistanès.
Ara aquí, darrere meu,
hi ha una muntanya de 7.795 metres.
El Batura Sar.
Llàstima que estigui un mica
ennubolat, eh?
A dalt.
Bueno, fa calor, eh?
A l'ombra no.
A l'ombra s'està esperat, de fet.
El polar està bé,
però el sol...
De fet trobo a faltar ara els pantalons de
cursa.
I la motxilla pesa.
Tinc ganes de treure'm ja la roba d'hivern,
la jaqueta aquesta que m'havies comprat a Tajikistan.
Però encara m'esperaré.
M'esperaré a sortir del Karakorum
per si faig algun trekking
una mica més alt o ja veurem.
Bueno, són la una i mitja.
Crec que d'aquí uns cinc quilòmetres
arribo a un poble
on potser puc dinar alguna cosa.
De moment, la caminada, molt agradable.
Pocs cotxes
i això em sorprèn bastant.
Bueno, els cotxes, mira, saps?
Pots camions? No hi ha camions?
N'hi ha molt pocs.
Jo m'esperava que això seria
com Tajikistan.
Que era una constant
de camions venint
i anant cap a la Xina.
La carretera en millor estat, molt millor estat que l'Alpamir.
Pakistan, un país que suposo
que li deu interessar
comercial bastant amb la Xina, tenen bona relació.
Per què? Per què no hi ha tants camions?
La carretera és difícil anar fins allà.
Home, sí, però Alpamir encara és més difícil.
Doncs tinc una teoria.
Tinc una teoria que és que
Pakistan té port. Pakistan té accés al mar.
Crec que es diu Karachi.
L'ajuten més al sud de Pakistan.
I jo crec que el comerç amb la Xina, i amb tots els altres països,
el fan per mar, perquè el comerç marítim és més eficient,
més econòmic, permet portar més coses,
no depèn de meteorologia, perquè clar, això a l'hivern està tancat,
etcètera, etcètera.
En canvi, Tajikistan no.
És un país que no té sortida del mar, llavors clar,
tot el comerç amb la Xina l'han de fer per carretera.
I imagino que aquest serà el motiu.
També, ara que hi penso, que és que sóc més burro que una sabata,
la frontera amb la Xina està tancada.
Està tancada l'1 al 4 d'octubre.
És clar que no hi ha camions.
És que jo també.
Bueno, veurem si els 5-6 hi ha més trànsit o no.
Fins demà!
Quina passada les vistes d'aquest poble Passo!
Tenim això d'aquí darrere, que no són muntanyes nevades,
però és brutal aquesta forma de piràmide que tenen.
Espectacular.
Aquí al davant tenim aquestes, que són superaltes.
Aquesta és un 7000, diria, una d'aquestes.
I aquestes sí que tenen neu, una glacera.
Hi ha unes altres que estan una mica amagades pels núvols.
Bueno, aquí al principi hi ha un restaurant, hi ha en vàrius,
però un d'ells, les reviews que tinc guardades al Google Maps Offline,
tenen bona pinta.
En aquest restaurant fan carn de llac, com es pot veure.
Un joc molt modern i molt guai, eh?
Amb les vistes aquí a totes les muntanyes, aquí,
amb aquestes finestrals, les taules de fusta superxules.
I no sé si l'escoltes, espero que no l'escolti,
perquè hi ha música en drets d'autom.
I, bueno, sobre el repte, el repte de la Xina.
Us en recordeu, el tema del rollito de primavera?
Doncs no, no el vaig trobar.
Vaig trobar una espècie de rollito enrotllat, però no era com cruixent,
que és el típic rollito, no.
No, no, no, els que em vau dir que no el trobaria, teníeu raó.
No el vaig trobar, repte perdut.
I el repte de Pakistan, una cosa que havia pensat era intentar escoltar música.
Música amb instruments.
Per què?
Perquè a les branques més conservadores de l'Islam,
la música amb instruments està prohibida.
Sí, està prohibit, és pecat escoltar música.
Però acabo d'entrar a aquest restaurant i tenen música.
Música màquina, música electrònica, per tant, no.
Repte perdut.
De fet, és que tenim una visió de Pakistan, jo inclòs, que potser no és la correcta.
És el cinquè país més poblat del món, crec.
Bueno, si no és el cinquè.
És un dels països més poblats del món.
Té moltes regions, Pakistan.
Jo crec que deuen tenir moltes ideologies diferents i...
Alguns sí que deuen pensar una mica així, però altres no tant.
Boníssima l'hamburguesa, amb aquestes patates salsa i un 7up 4,60.
Molt bon preu, no?
Ai, Enric, hauries de provar menjar pakistanès.
Va, eh, no.
Ja tindrem temps de provar-ho.
Bueno, total.
En la broma, en la broma, ja són les quatre menys quart.
Tu, clar, si has començat tan tard...
Porto vint quilòmetres.
Porto vint quilòmetres, només.
Per tal com a molt, faré trenta, trenta i pico, si allargo.
Bueno, a veure on acabo, vull.
Per si no n'hi havia a prova amb la vall glaciar aquesta
i les muntanyes aquestes brutals de fons,
et dónes la volta mentre estava caminant cap allà
i faaa!
Faaa!
La glacera de Passo.
Hi ha una glacera aquí, tio!
I es veu des de la carretera del Caracoro.
Què és això?
És brutal.
Fuà!
Però és que no és que et vegis que has de pujar molt, eh?
Vull dir, està aquí, està aquí mateix.
Diu la senyal aquesta que al final de la glacera
es veu el pic de Passo, que té 7.500 metres,
però avui hi ha núvols i no es veu.
Però buà, tio!
Brutal!
Els dos dies que porto a Pakistan,
us he ensenyat uns quants ponts de suspensió.
Mireu aquest, no sé si es veu.
És el pont de suspensió de Passo.
És el pont de suspensió més llarg de tota aquesta regió,
la regió de Guilt i Baltestan.
Ara mateix, com veieu, hi ha dues persones allà creuant.
És molt louc.
O sigui, aquest pont, fixeu-vos que no va massa enlloc,
perquè aquí hi ha aquesta espècie de condes i avissades gegants,
que hi ha algunes terres allà,
hi ha algunes terres allà, però per connectar d'aquí a aquí
jo no veig res, no veig cap població.
No sé on va aquest pont.
És llarguíssim, eh?
Potser m'agradaria haver anat a creuar-lo.
Molt louc.
Són les 5 i 10.
Aquesta esplanada d'aquí seria bastant ideal per acampar.
Està a la vista de la carretera totalment,
però és molt pla i ara mateix no fa massa vent aquí,
potser està una mica reservat.
Però, però, no tinc molta aigua.
Aquí falta la previsió.
Podria demanar-los aquests cotxes, de fet.
A veure si em poden donar una mica d'aigua.
O podria continuar i anar un altre cop a un hotel.
Crec que faré això, sí.
Hi ha moltes opcions d'hotel aquí en aquesta vall
i en els següents quilòmetres,
bastant bé de preu i mira, ja està, saps?
A veure si em poden donar una mica d'aigua.
Les 6 menys quart, hora de la posta de sol.
Just passo per un lloc on posa Oxus Inn
i hi havia un home aquí molt simpàtic i li pregunto
How much?
I diu 2,000, que vol que són 6 euros.
Perfecte, m'està bé.
I ara m'estan ensenyant les habitacions.
M'ha ensenyat una que tenia molt bona pinta.
Diu, espera, espera, que fa una mica d'olor.
No sé de què.
Vaig a ensenyar-te l'altra.
Però bé, ja està bé.
És l'hora de la posta de sol, però és d'hora en realitat.
I aprofito per anar a veure el pont de suspensió
que té aquest poble.
Potser em penedeixo perquè he de baixar
i després tornar a pujar tot.
Però bé, no porto la motxilla, l'he de tallar.
Thank you.
Bueno, s'havia de pagar tiquet.
I no porto efectiu a sobre.
I a més, doncs ara s'està fent fosc.
Així que si he de pagar el tiquet, doncs ja vindré demà.
Bueno, si he de pagar el tiquet, serà un lloc guapo, no?
Com a mín serà segur.
Clar, si he de pagar tiquet espero que el pont sigui segur.
Doncs res, torno amb la cua entre les cames al hostel.
També aquí hi ha bastantes botigues de souvenirs,
però no tenen postals.
He preguntat i no tenen postals.
Seria un puntasso ja enviar-les des d'aquí, eh?
Ja tindria l'octubre solucionat.
M'encanta acampar.
I ara fa temps que no ho faig.
Però una habitació així...
per 6 euros?
Pff...
Costa dir que no, eh?
Dit això, es nota que fa temps que no ve ningú aquí.
M'ho ha comentat ara el de l'hotel i també m'ho van dir ahir.
Que si aquest any hi ha menys turisme,
bastant menys turisme de l'habitual,
per culpa de la guerra a Mirant.
No perquè a la gent li faci por venir aquí.
Clar, jo què sé, potser sí.
Perquè Pakistan té frontera a Mirant.
Sinó el que em van comentar ahir era el tema dels avions.
Per culpa de la guerra aquesta hi ha hagut una mica de disrupció del tràfic
que feia escala a Dubai o a Emirats.
No, Emirats és Dubai.
A Qatar o a Emirats.
Llavors, o hi ha hagut menys avions o...
Bueno, algo així.
Ja es veu que hi ha menys turisme aquest any aquí.
Sí, sí, sí.
M'ha ofert sopar però he dit que no.
Perquè avui la veritat és que no tinc massa gana.
He fet només 30 quilòmetres avui.
No, no arriba.
20 i pico.
28 i pico.
No arriba, no arriba.
Bueno, sí.
Demà m'aixecaré més d'hora.
Espero.
Demà és que he d'arribar a Hansa.
He d'arribar al lloc on he de comprar les cims, sí o sí.
I són 40 i pocs quilòmetres.
Per tant, demà més en val matinar.
Sí.
Suposo que vinc ben alimentat de la Xina i ja està.
Bueno, què tal les sabates?
Les sabates noves aquestes que m'he comprat a la Xina.
Doncs a part d'estar ja poc negres.
Aquestes sabates originalment eren negres.
Però amb la pols ja no.
A part d'això, súper còmodes.
Súper, súper còmodes.
Molt bé.
Molt, molt bé.
La tracció no l'he provat perquè caminant per carretera, doncs...
Bueno, no rellisques, evidentment.
I el tema de la transpirabilitat,
que era una cosa que em preocupava, doncs...
Bueno, no sé.
Aquests dies potser no ha fet tanta calor i...
Noto que potser em sua alguna mica el peu,
però res, exagerat de moment.
El que sí que...
Tots aquests dies que he estat caminant amb elles
no he estat tenint cap problema a...
O sigui, vaig notar que era la bona talla.
Però avui he començat a notar que se'm feien petites.
Potser no les tinc suficientment lligades, ben lligades.
Però sí, hi ha hagut parts del dia, doncs,
que el dit m'anava tocant a la punta.
Res dramàtic.
Però, ostres, jo quan me les vaig provar no ho semblava.
Bueno.
Potser me les he de lligar millor.
A part d'això, ha sigut un dia espectacular.
Top 5, jo diria, de paisatges.
A part del dia ha sigut superplàcid i supertranquil, superbé.
Top 5 de paisatges de la volta al món a peu, potser, eh?
Increïble.
Crec que això de la carretera aquesta del Karakorum
és el que necessitava just ara.
Perquè no volia ni tots els dies
que estigués a casa,
perquè no volia ni tota la tecnologia
i comoditats de la Xina,
que és on venia, i totes les regles,
però tampoc una cosa tan dura com el Pamir,
que va ser brutal i va valer la pena, eh?
Però necessitava alguna cosa
una mica més tranquil.
I aquesta part de Pakistan
només porta dos dies.
Costa fer extrapolacions.
Però de moment, superbé.
Demà,
més, senyores i senyors.
Bona nit.
Fins demà.